this guy is an operator and operators  are intimidating  you know why operators are intimidating  because operators don't just say things  to say him Biden will say things to get  elected every 90 percent of people that  are running for office they'll say  whatever they can to get elected because  the history is about what it's about who  got elected right every once in a while  you find a person that you know how they  say I'm gonna kick your ass they're  actually going to kick your ass okay  those types of people are very scary so  to the only thing that he made a point  that makes you think is the following  so let's just say  you know how different are Trump and  DeSantis  if they're pushing this hard for Trump  to be eliminated because they want to  indict him so he can't run what they're  really saying is we would much rather  face up the scientist and face off  transfer